yeah welcome to this video playing Grand
Master Dina meat from from Russia and
again I have forgotten his name I need
to check it again auto a Galilean God da
Liang ok GM would more than 2,500 rating
let's see I'm going before the open a
line again or the hoop in a line I
should actually pronounce the name like
it is in German yeah why does not need
to okay but he plays the usual advance
yeah we have a typical closed center to
the color of the variation and I'm
trying to quickly prepare an f5
counterplay 98 to prepare f5 and he is
immediately try to play against that
maybe I should have played 96 first
hmm Jim maybe I should have now he's got
ideas to go for a formerly quickly but
have not text if I'd as a response okay
I need to play be six anyway to make yes
he just plays it 95 wasn't my intention
95 takes Queen edge from not sure okay
if it's not working what what can you do
with just one game I'm just attacking
the knight on edge form so it's a quite
clear what what his idea was maybe there
wasn't any you just missed the move
possible yeah the problem is that I'm
also just threatening night except for
so you yeah cannot play a random slow
moves I'd hope for the best you need to
do something okay just recapture the
deep own
yeah yeah okay I need to I need to
retreat probably anyway and prepare 96
if i manage 96 without any ninety six
left five without any director
punishment then like ass all excellent
shape but he at the moment has this
temporary activity the bishop on d3 and
the open FR me down ideas what part if
he goes night if night Queenie for what
about this threatening mate and also i'm
intending to play d 6 okay i can
probably play a fire okay it's not
happening so let's consider this should
i play eve for not the same I just f5 f5
here will probably play Bishop g5 I have
Queen f7 now who kept hard to decide
really hard to decide Bishop takes I
have g 6 km so this smooth night all
night f6 Bishop takes rook takes Bishop
f5 still g6 yeah okay
yessum some pressure him yeah it's still
not completely easy to play maybe I
should just play h6 next page six
attacking the the bishop I couldn't have
taken I could have taken them the queen
but Bishop e7 is quite annoying
attacking the rook intending d6 ok at
least I'm glad that that he's spending
some time
yeah I actually expected some something
dramatic like that but age six what
about age six takes takes rook takes
takes on a five well can do that
hmm not i'm not sure if i move the Queen
just move it to some good square not
quite sure what square but let's say
Queenie fire what to see participating
against that Jiggs hmm yeah it's not too
clear actually I would need to need to
do somewhere else okay let's let's do
that I need to play with now we're
taking the Queen
what the heck I completely what I just
just a pin on the fifth-ranked got great
oh wow yeah tactics are more important
than any any strategical considerations
it's just it's just like that white
white already was completely outplayed
but if you allow it this kind of stuff
it doesn't matter check check you can
just take a five this is the problem
very very simple chat hey maybe no no
way to no way to save this problem at
least isn't open time morning Lisa it's
a pen
he cannot made me queen takes with ELQ
a.m. on 11 seconds check yeah I will
burn on time the position as it's not so
clear I think yeah maybe White has a win
with the deep or something but I lost
the game beforehand so not you checked
off of time you shouldn't have survived
the only Miller game yeah bouquet fade
black for effects on time take a look at
fades door okay fades to Queen you fall
yeah I like sorry I just overlooked
group takes e4 which makes Queenie five
completely ridiculous yeah like it's
just winning with good play but i didn't
i didn't didn't find it Queenie five
honey and I even have an additional
minute Joe the easiest is this one just
winning the game i briefly considered
that but actually failed to recognize
that I'm attacking the bishop now and
this means that he doesn't really have a
move I can take but this is just just
completely completely hopeless so Bishop
here right at five Bishop da truck t8
gtx g6 and resigns that's it like it's
just winning with two connected passes
and the better structure and so on yeah
just just very easy
and he basically blundered the pawn with
no compensation at all at least them how
he played it there was no compensation
Queenie for was interesting maybe Bishop
f4 but this is just just hopeless
basically but it's a game of two persons
and if the the other person me in this
case please like brain-dead to term it
it's not helping yeah yeah should play
Queen have successes maybe still a game
but after this I'm just toast yeah
tactic some drive over strategy this is
simply the simple truth Queen d8 however
would have put an end to the game it's
not the only move but a good enough one
even a second-rate move like we never
seven is just sick the edge I simply
forgot about rookie phone okay thanks
for watching